there are two presenters for the next
award one of them is Miss Cyd Charisse
the other is Tony Martin mr. Martin is
married to Miss Charisse I point that
out to you because mr. Martin pointed it
out to me
sidqa recent Tony Martin
we are privileged to present Oscars to
some gentlemen who have always been kind
to us the cinematographers would you
read the nominees sit
the nominees for black and white
cinematography our Joseph Michelle for
the apartment child belaying junior for
the facts of life and is Laszlo go
inherit the wind Jon L Russell for
psycho and Freddie Francis four sons and
lovers and the winner Tony he the winner
is Sons and Lovers Freddie Francis
accepting for Freddie Prentiss is Jerry
water
no I'm not pretty Francis but I am
excepting for them thank you very much
nominees for the best achievement in
color cinematography are William H for
the a for the Alamo
Joseph Ruttenberg and Charles Hardin for
Butterfield 8 Sam Levitt for Exodus Joe
McDonald for Pepe and Russel Mehdi
for Spartacus and the winner SID
very happy to accept this thank all my
crew the group that helped make
Spartacus what turned out to be thank
you